you heard about the news what happened
to those uh innocent 49 people who got
gunned down in new zealand
you asked like well wow as you're
admiring the bridge
and you said well who put this together
who's the designer do you hear about
what happened in new zealand any
thoughts on
dino palace uh billy duker from dieber
macedonia
i'm niku from dieber i'm worried that
wasn't a gunshot
the more i looked into it the more i
found out that it was you know from
from god from allah i'm we're from new
york actually so just living the new
york life
that he came from hinduism and he
accepted islam and i asked him
what was it about islam and you said the
life of the
the life of the grave that really scared
me and i just realized i had to change
here in queens new york jesus the son of
mary so it's a mosque
named after jesus one of the greatest
messengers in islam
remember a story of bible yeah yeah
yeah inshallah will be soon in
sarajevo but we got sarah evo here in
new york look at that
taste of sarevo in new york
you hear about what happened in new
zealand and your thoughts on
no i didn't see it you didn't see it
okay
okay check it out and check out the dean
show how's that thank you very much hi
from new york happy new york big apple
there you go thank you ron
thank you you have a good day you too
nice people in new york
and that's why it's very important
education is a key
because people do very irrational and
crazy things when they're scared
make the human connection with muslims
go visit muslims in a mosque
muslims get out there knock on doors
invite people
to your masjids so you can go ahead and
make a difference
because the media is pumping people up
and the hate provocateurs
over a quarter a million dollars minimum
is being spent
to demonize to
create fear of muslims negative
propaganda
you got to get out there and be
ambassadors to your deen
it's a mandate from allah go out there
and share if you care
you heard about the news what happened
to those uh innocent 49 people who got
gunned down in new zealand
yeah yeah pretty bad yeah sad
what are your thoughts about that we
gotta watch it today you know
yeah thank you okay
and new york queens still yes we're
still in new york we're eating real food
yeah it's real food avoid fake food he's
turn it turn this out it's a real nice
place what's this called
uh fusion juice bar fusion juice bar
look at it beautiful they got some
really nice variety of
whose real foods to eat and this is the
investment
worth investing in you know you'll
invest in
your car to make sure it's going to get
you from point a to point b but what
about your body your health
you know we've been told that this is
the
besides time one of the other blessings
health that people take for granted
you got cancer on the rise one in two
men one in three women
suspected have cancer chronic diseases
skyrocketing through the roof
and 95 of those chronic diseases are
food related
so we get our food and nutrition right
god will inshaallah then we can
make other lifestyle adjustments clean
water
good sleep good rest exercise very
important
movement and if we can implement these
small things and stopping the
invaders that are coming in the toxic
poisons that we're putting in our body
inflaming the body and then we're
getting sick
so nutrition along with obviously
building that on a good heart
a healthy heart taking care of the
soul and from there taking care of our
body our mind and all these things are
connected
all these are components for true
happiness you cannot neglect one
or the other they all have their place
this is a great place
to visit and a great little reminder
to not put garbage in this body that
allah the creator created for us because
it's not a garbage can
so he wrote food avoid great food here
in new york we're just talking about
how property values are starting to go
up
in the area where the muslims pray the
house of god the house of allah
the masjid so share that with us what
you were saying about
when we opened the jesus son of mary
mosque in uh in new york city in hollis
queens
we we opened it in an area that real
estate wasn't really booming
um you know there was houses right next
to the to the to the mosque that we're
going for like 250 000
and we opened in 2011 those same houses
now
are worth 750 000 plus so the real
estate went up 200 percent
and i've seen it with my own eyes
several business owners actually
wanting to build larger buildings larger
facilities and asking for messages
to be on the first floor because they
know that a is going to
increase the real estate value and b it
brings you know a lot of the community
together so it's it's really something
amazing to see the impact of the the
house of god what it does to a community
yeah i've seen where actually crime has
gone down
right police are more happy you know the
the community is happier but um a lot of
times you get this negative push they
don't want
moss in their town but now you're
actually showing the the good side the
flip side that people need to hear
yeah the businessmen and the
entrepreneurs know they want
they want the mosque there because their
real estate value goes up
building values they make money
businessmen
because of because of that value you
know even even over here in new york
city the nypd the captain thanked us
personally he said thank you for what
you're doing for the community because
they know the value
that's for sure so that's the the the
who thanked the community the new york
police nypd new york police department
the captain yeah the captain
wow what about so also crime we
mentioned crime going down on
neighborhood absolutely crime gone down
several areas i mean
key ex you know one of the best examples
here in new york is is in brooklyn
you know brooklyn huge area of drug drug
problems
and uh you know message was built and
everything got started getting wiped out
big avenue we're on jamaica we're not in
jamaica
we're in jamaica on jamaica avenue
in queens where's brooklyn
looking spa brooklyn spa
bob are you cold
almost
[Music]
don't worry that wasn't a gunshot
we're in new york
very much up and coming excuse me it's
becoming the mini manhattan
[Music]
the muslims in the uh new zealand it's
sad
i don't know really it's just i don't
want to go with that it's it's
sad yeah yeah people died innocent more
so now
i'm muslim actually i got it yeah and a
lot of times you know any anytime
something is perpetrated by some lunatic
who's not even practicing islam
they put islam you know on the stand you
know what i'm saying
so we've we've originally founded the
haybusters
after the murder
of um via north carolina
remember the three muslims that were
there may allah have mercy on them
their neighbor had killed them uh
the guy who killed him in their home
yeah so when we looked at that situation
we'll have mercy on them and their
families i mean
we looked at that situation we said to
ourselves that
there has to be a way where we can show
people what islam is
and be able to show it from a different
perspective so we we
started the hate busters we have a big
team hamdulillah with the hay busters
and basically the hate busters mission
is to bust hate with love
so we know that there's hate that exists
out there we know it's there
and that's fine people
have their own prerogative they have
their own opinions you know
they got the real food here now they
uh they have they're entitled to their
own opinions but we wanted to bring
islam from a different perspective so
one of the things we did with the hate
busters is we launched the hate buster
trucks
so the haybuster trucks they drive
around major cities across the united
states with loving messages about islam
so for example we have hadith of the
prophet some that the best of you
are the best towards women right so we
took a truck
we drove around lower manhattan we went
to maryland we went to jersey we went to
cities you know across the u.s
and the beautiful thing about the
haybuster truck is you can't avoid it
it comes right in front of you right in
front of your eyes uh
and their response was just amazing i
mean people looked at a different
perspective
of islam and we also did uh some
hate-busting activities where we
we brought trucks with messages and
hadith of the prophet so i saw them
and we asked people if they agreed with
the
the prophet sallallahu islam and a lot
of people said yes we agree with the
prophet muhammad
which is an amazing door for them to
start learning about islam
we also gave them roses you know we
exchanged a lot of
information you know in times square we
had people accept islam as well
you know through our initiative so that
was there was a great success coming
up busting the hate with love educating
the people
and that's the way to go huh with all
this misinformation
more of this is needed and this is where
we're lacking
so it's very exciting to see people who
are out there
who are doing their best and hopefully
we can motivate more people
to go ahead and try to bust the hate
with the love with
educating the people so with kareem here
we got what do we got here we got some
brought us here we're getting some real
food beautiful look at that huh
allah blessed us beautiful so we can
have
some avocados masala
some eggs these are i believe
uh from or organic pasture raised huh
that's what it looks like yeah not
conventional eggs
and then what do we got here we got
carrot ginger kale
spinach all the good stuff medicine
here in new jersey and uh i got some uh
we got
montenegro from montenegro and uh where
you guys from
montenegro introduce yourself from
montenegro
uh billy duker from dieber macedonia
for me for about what now almost 15
16 years yeah what was it about islam
that had you turn your life around
towards practicing it
i guess it was just i was just
on the internet and i heard a lot of
people just saying bad things about
islam and then i figured
since i'm muslim i might as well you
know start looking into it and then the
more i looked into it
the more i found out that it was you
know from from god from allah
yeah what about you guys oh i've been
practicing for two and a half years now
alhamdulillah
why well i used to be a little religious
when i was younger probably 13 years old
and then i got caught up in the typical
american lifestyle i guess called it
i'm from new york actually so just live
in the new york life
caught up and then i remember certain
hadiths that just got to me
you know the the life of the the life of
the grave that really scared me
and i just realized i had to change it
and alhamdulillah
same here i came here 10 years ago
and you know just like everybody else
when you first come here
then i started practicing like five
years ago
i had a mosque close to my house
meeting brothers from all over the place
nice meeting you brothers
what happened uh there was a
an attack on people who went to the
mosque
were muslim so it was you know usually
they'd call it muslim terrorists right
yeah so the muslims were in there
praying juma
is the time of the week yeah we're going
to pray are you muslim
no i'm just afraid of this not yet
muslim will call you
you know you know there's a mosque here
yeah i know i just have a lot of friends
that go to them you should stop it man
yeah i'll be trying this hey this is uh
uh we gotta not get muslim
adrian smith what do you know about
islam all i know is ramadan i ain't go
for it
you know you know yeah you're going to
stop it sometimes uh this is one yeah
thank you
that he came from hinduism and he
accepted islam and i asked him
what was it about islam and you said it
was the oneness of god
it started from being believing in one
god and the prophets
what what's the basic belief system of
hinduism
there is no the way i say it it comes
from various scriptures
the basic should be oneness of god but
it i don't i don't find it in the
regular
uh life where people believe it it's
generally spread across many
idols which is not acceptable for me
eventually
i had to accept what the message of
islam said so for all our brothers from
hyderabad that's where you're originally
from but the sad thing was
nobody was giving you a dawah there or
representing did you feel islam
what were you saying that you couldn't
find the ideal person or
or islam the way you the way that was
practiced
what were you explaining explain that to
me again that's fine i had a lot of
muslims in the class and there was
nothing to learn from
from them because they were known for
notorious notorious behavior
so i i was keeping myself amongst my own
circle of friends
but i came to learn islam when i got to
us when i befriended a few brothers who
were very religious
and we had a discussion and we shared a
lot of topic between my religion and
islam at that time and then i eventually
took six to seven months and then
a lot opened my heart and then i became
a muslim how did you find out about the
dean show
through i don't remember how but i think
it came under recommendations because i
was following the
speakers islamic speakers as well as
brother ahmadi dad speaker lectures
so that's how yours popped up and then i
followed you from there because i
i started seeing your topics on
interviewing people and brother muhammad
hijab
that's where i started following you yes
i examined my brother muhammad
when he came here for the debate so what
advice would you have for other people
who are from the hindu background but
they're also
having this problem with you know
worshiping multiple gods and
they like the idea the concept of
worshiping only one god what advice
would you have for them where to start
open your heart first off if you believe
in something
ask questions where the belief came from
and what's the source if the source
convinces you
then we cannot i we cannot really force
you to believe
or there's nobody else should be able to
force you
but what you have to understand is where
did that information come from check
your information
and then based on that take it from
there if you have seen
if you believe in certain book why do
you believe in the book and
what evidence does it have to back up in
my case if
if i have if i were to follow the quran
and the hadees i
see where the evidence comes from who
who was it revealed to we know the
person who was revealed to and the
interpretation from the person was
revealed to and there's evidence to back
up
there's any scripture you follow see
where the sources come from it applies
to the bible as well
see where the evidence comes from do you
actually have the evidence
and do you have the interpretation from
the person who it was revealed to if
there's none then check your resources
check your resources
what were uh a couple of the the
struggles that you went through
how did you overcome them i guess we'll
we will always
he will test you when you accept islam
and it did
my parents did give me a tough time and
you stick with stick with
what the truth is there is no going back
if you believe something is right
you have to believe that's right there
is no compromise and when you stick with
it
it's your relation with allah first then
it's anybody else so stick with your
creator
than anybody else do you do you see more
and more hindus coming to islam have you
witnessed that
not much but i have met um hindus
definitely who are three words over here
um but very rare in general i see
christians more but hindu is very rare
because
because when they are brought up they
have this notion of hating
muslims or christians that has to be
worked on first so the person has to be
willing to be open
for ideas or for beliefs all right thank
you for
thank you for spending a few minutes
with us introducing yourself and sharing
your story in the condensed version
thank you
this is a astoria park a store a story
apartment this is astoria park
in queens
try what is it triboro bridge try boral
bridge
yeah and then you also have rules of the
island the view of roseville island
[Music]
you know just looking at this bridge and
i don't know some of you have seen this
bridge maybe on some pictures or
didn't see it like first hand beautiful
beautiful man-made invention to get
people from one side to the other
but imagine if we're just having a
conversation i said
you asked me so or asked the person
but imagine if someone said hey so i
wonder who created this
who put this together and then
your buddy said uh what are you
what are you talking about it just
happened by chance
there's no designer behind this what
would you think
you know what you think there's more
chances of that creating itself
than this whole universe
which is absurd isn't it where are some
people going with that
i was observing this bridge and i
thought
imagine having a conversation with
someone and then
you ask like well wow as you're admiring
the bridge
and you said well who put this together
who's the designer
and the person looked at you bewildered
and said why are you asking me that
yes that there there is no one it just
happened by chance
what do you think would that be
acceptable in a way in a logical
conversation
no way no way bridge can't come that
bridge can't come by itself
out of random choice point zero zero
zero one chance it's impossible
it's not gonna happen it wasn't it
wasn't put together
but chance it was put together for a
purpose but but
everyone i think everybody's like that's
100 percent like consensus everybody's
on the same page we got a thumbs up
but why do people attribute foolishness
down to the creation
to the universe that it just happened by
chance
you know it's hard to say it's hard to
say in my experience
what i've noticed and a lot of other
people that i've spoken to as well
they've noticed this as well is that
a lot of people who either leave their
faith
or have doubts about their faith or
let's say become atheists or even bash
religions right there's usually an
emotional
uh attachment to that
meaning that there's something that
happened to that person
in their life and they're taking it out
on their faith
that's usually my experience what i've
seen so you know most people that i've
talked to especially let's say muslims
muslims that i'm talking to um because
i'm muslim i talk to muslims
the ones who are doubtful about their
faith you know the ones who say they
want to leave islam when you really
start having
conversations with them digging deeper
and deeper you realize that there's a
problem
there's a problem that they're they have
in their lives with their family
something happened to them
the people around them the way they
treat them so usually something comes
down to that
you know yeah that makes sense so it's
really it's really
at the end of the day it's not something
logical it's more emotional
yes exactly yeah and i've seen that also
yeah definitely more emotions
i mean look look at the bridge you can't
you can't deny it
you can't deny it so it's definitely
definitely more emotion
than logic absolutely so come on guys
you can't deny the bridge
but what about the one who created this
whole creation
and everything in it that's logical it
makes sense design indicates a designer
here in new york